hello everybody and welcome you all
so
we're gonna talk about something very
interesting topic of the day
and that is called hooks in react
see friends actually what happens
when we work on react-based development
so in react 16.8
we have introduced a new feature called
react hooks
these hooks have
really changed the way how the react
development really happens
because prior to these react hooks
we were writing so much of code because
of that it actually increased the
complexity to our program
but ever since the react hooks came into
this picture the development time has
slows down
okay and we have actually increased the
productivity of our development
now how the react hook really changes
the way
this we're gonna see it now in those
slides
now what are the react hooks see the
react hook is a special feature that
lets you hook intro
now what is this
see they say fuse important thing they
say normally hook allows you to reuse a
stateful logic without changing your
component hierarchy
your application can actually divide it
into the smaller pieces which later on
can be used together
okay so hooks let you use most of the
react features without using classes see
actually what happens
in react we have a two type of ways how
you write your components number one is
called class based component and second
which is called functional component
now
class based components are little more
heavy lifting because it comes
pre-loaded with state management as well
as the life cycle management
but not always you need these two
so you need to keep your components
light weighted so if you want to keep
your components light weighted so you
need to basically approach towards the
state
less or functional component so by
adding those hooks feature so you can
have this normal functional components
on the top of that you will be having
some add-on feature that's the beauty of
react hooks
now the rules of react hooks
so there are few rules of the react
hooks which you need to understand
and what those are
number one
they say
only call hooks
at the top level
don't look hooks inside loops conditions
or nested function so there are certain
conditions
they say
only hooks only call hooks from the
react function component don't call
hooks from the regular javascript
function instead you can call hook from
the react function component or call
hooks from the custom box so there are
multiple options are available which you
can expose or use in your regular
react-based applications
okay
so after that we will see the demo how
the three different type of hooks are
used state hooks event hooks and create
customized hook and we will see some
demo on the top of that
hello everybody so once again we are
going to start working with another type
of oxy
in our previous examples we have seen
how you can have the state related hook
now my next event will be all about how
you can have
the
even based hooks we're talking about
something called use effects so how the
usefx really works let's take a look now
so here
in a similar example if i just give the
name call
[Music]
okay let's try to make it here only so
what i'm trying to do now is in my
current application
i'm already having this count and set
count to me but
i can also provide some default values
that anyways has been provided so rather
than hard coding it i can provide it
from somewhere else so how we can
so let's use one property called props
here
and here rather than providing this i'm
saying
prob start count so my question is like
what do you mean by count here
see count is nothing but a property
which initial value i don't know so
which you can set it from outside
so what you can do is here
before you export it you can say give
the name call
hook stand dot
default props
default
props
okay equal to i'm starting with the
curly braces
and after this curly braces here saying
count
okay that value is what
zero
what initial value we're giving count
initial value equal to what zero now and
uh post this
this value whichever we are giving it
so what we also do in the same line is
here we would like to also perform the
another actions for setting the state
initial value is called count
and
this way i can say set count count plus
one
okay that is anyways fine
so increment let me copy this
so here let me say npm space start
so i must see some values have been
presented okay you can see still
initial value was zero
that's why if you see initial value was
zero so now because of getting the
initial value called props dot count and
now i can say increment
and i want to talk about decrement so
decrement and here we say reset
so
here
we can say minus 1 and this value rather
than saying count plus one
okay
you can say
props dot count means whatever the
initial value would be that value will
be initialized here
so now the code will work just the way
it is now you can say increment
decrement reset
so it's working fine
so in our react hooks is of an option
which is available called
life cycle hooks
life cycle books are very very important
that means you're trying to say
whenever you would like to call anything
related to your life cycle like when
your component starts you would like to
learn something when the component
you know update you want to learn
something so these kind of activities
you can certainly make it so how you
gonna be making it now let's take a look
now so initially what i'm doing is
i'm just
creating a new function called
use
because it is a predefined
okay available from
okay react 16
so here onwards you can see it is coming
from the same property from react and
under this use effect what i will do is
i will just say
log and i'm saying
called
every time
now if i just launch my application and
see the inspect
you can see it is saying called every
time even if i say increment it is
getting called even decremented is
getting called and reset it will get
called
because this is a life cycle method and
the life cycle method means it will get
called
normally in a react we have a call
component dead mount and component data
update so it is a copy of both
okay
however you can
is stick this particular use effect to
the specific need only like if you do
not want this to be get called
on updates only when the component
launches so what you can do here in its
comma parameter you can make it as a
square bracket
this is square bracket will contain
those values which you would like to
watch for those changes
so if you do not keep it anything by
default it will be what
blank so now if i just go ahead and
start it is saying called every time and
now you can say
it is not getting called at all because
now
it is knowing that hey it is a blank
value so i'm not seeing any value so it
needs to be get called only when it is
launching
not every time
however you also can offer the condition
where you want to call this use effect
only when the changes happens not
every time when it is loading
so what you can do you can just call
this
again
and paste it again this use effect and
say called
on
update and here you can provide the
value which you would like to listen so
actually if i see the state is getting
changed for this count so i can say
count and now once it is ready
i can start my application
and you can say here
increment now you can see it is getting
called
okay but it is not getting called on
loading every time
so you are specifically telling
like
this use effect should get called only
when
state changes to the count and this you
are not listening to anything so you are
making it as applying
i hope you are clear about what use
effect is all about
okay everyone so the previous example we
have seen like how
this books with regards to your uh
current application works like as i'm
saying we're talking about like in
this
state hook where we have seen use effect
we have also seen another feature that
is known as called use state and now
we're going to be talking about our next
okay everyone so now
we're continuing to our next feature
here and that is known as called use
context see when we talk about react use
context we always have a
very special feature coming up with us
where the reusability comes as a
priority
okay so if you really want to use a
reusability
okay you always think about the option
called use context now first of all i
would like to show you the problem
and then we discussed about the solution
so now here
i'm gonna say
use
context.js and in this use context.js
what i'll be doing is i'll be creating
some few functions here i'm saying
function
name
okay
so in this manner i can create
const
i can say
user
set user equal to
use
state and initialize the value which
call what
admin that is the initial value we are
saying like in main app user set user
use state admin
and now after this
i am using return
and in this return
with my div tag i would like to offer
the message
okay so we are giving the name called
h2 and within this h2 we are
using this a value called
welcome and with this dollar sign
we can give the value like a user
whichever the initial value will be that
will be represented here
so that's what my first component
likewise
if i want to share the data
to the other components
how i basically try to use that's an
important thing i would like to consider
right now
so this is my first component
like i also want to create another
component which is accepting the data
and utilizing its own way
okay so like this
i can copy
and say
user2
for this function i'm creating this user
tool
in this user tool
i will not be defining any state as of
now because it is there already defined
okay so in this it will be expecting
here it will be expecting
user as in parameter okay so return
you can define it anything i can say
paragraph
in this i can say
[Music]
user2 component
okay and i'm saying
component 2 and now i would like to pass
this value further to the another
component now
so what i'm trying to say now here
if i say user 2
let me copy this the whole bunch
and paste it below here and i'm saying
user3
which is also taking this data
and here
i'm defining this value called
user3
okay space
user
equal to
user
like this
we are providing it
okay
so that's where
i'm trying to use this
functionality so we are having this
function user two
okay so after this
we are taking function three and adding
the data right over there
okay so this div tag whichever you're
taking it
so we have a call main app we can say
user two and forward per user three so
the data we can keep on passing from one
copper into another component so we have
got this component with me
user 2 and same time people call user 3
now
ok and this user 2 whichever is
available to me
ok when you're saying hello user
this user 2 i can provide this data
right over here
ok so in my main application i can say
uh
user
two
okay and with this we can provide the
value called
user equal to
once again user
like this so you can see here
we are passing the data
down the line to all my components
whichever we are utilizing it
okay
so that's fine
so
after this what you'll be doing because
we are passing the data just like that
but the only thing is what if this main
app
wants to pass the data directly to the
user three it cannot pass
okay it can pass the data to the user
three only from its immediate child
which is a user too
and that's what the problem i would like
to sort it out but here
let me say
export
default
the name is called main app
okay let's make initial capital that is
always good
okay export default main app
and let's add this main app right inside
your
approaches
okay now let's see
see the value is coming up welcome admin
welcome admin recommended
so that's pretty fine
components are basically rendered but
there is no reusability if you see like
it is a
plain old technique
you pass the data to the child and you
cannot pass the chat to the grandchild
these are the certain challenges
okay so let's try to sort it out this
issue
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about the solution we have already
seen our problem
there's no reusability there's no
sharing of the data
and the sharing of the data is happening
from parent to child
only when you are a direct parent
otherwise not
so how are you going to be fixing this
issue
so fix this what i'll be doing is we
just want to say
const
app context equal to
create
context
okay so we're going to say equal to what
a create context so as usual the states
are there
return
now in this return what i will be doing
it i will be using this
context so anyways i'm having this dev
tag
so i'll be using this option like in
user context
or the context which you have created
that is called context so we are saying
what
app context here okay dot
you see there is an option available
called provider this is the one which
should be helping you to share the data
to the all the components value equal to
user
okay and this app context i would like
to cut it
okay and paste it after here
okay and here
user to equal user to whatever it is the
value is there so you are passing it to
user two
okay and later on you can pass to any
components those who want to really use
it
okay so whoever wants to access your
context it can be easily available
okay so you really don't need to pass
this data again and again so if you are
in second component
okay so your anyways wrap this second
component right over here
so here in your second component
you really don't need this any data like
this
and you really don't need this
like that so you can easily pass this
video to the user3 also
okay so it's very simple and
straightforward
so
let me try to remove this value from
here also
and you can get the data the way you
always want
okay so
you say value equal to what
user here
so after that you're saying
user equal to what user whichever value
you are basically passing it
okay and say use context.provider
okay and the second component
when you say user 2
you just say
you really don't need this in fact i
would say
you can even remove it
okay and the same you can remove it from
here also
okay and when i see my component swag
see
still working like the weight is
expected
okay so that becomes the idea of what
your
use context
okay which is designed for sharing the
data between and among the components
okay everyone so now it's time to
basically discuss about our another very
important topic that is called user f
okay use ref is basically what the used
ref you can say it is the kind of hook
which allows you to persist value
between the renders
again i'm telling you user f allows
actually to persist the value between
renders
normally you can store
or you can use to store a mutable values
which are changeable
okay that does not cause
a re-render when updated
okay
that means you can persist that value in
a storage okay as a mutable value which
does not cause
a re-render when the updates actually
happens so normally it can be used to
access your dom element directly
clear so how it can be let's take a look
with using one simple example
so you all can understand how we can
utilize this
okay so i'm gonna create another one
here
name call use ref dot
cheers
inside this use ref.js so let's get
started with this implementations the
one which we're looking at right now so
called user if so once again i'm
creating
a function
app
and inside this i would like to say
const
input
vl
comma
set
input val
equal to
user state
okay
we want to use it now we want to use one
more const
prep value
okay equal to now we would like to say
use
ref you can see it is coming once again
from the where from the react here in
this user we can pass initial value
black we do not have initial value so
that we are sending it as a what is a
blank
now post that
we want to create
first important thing is we would like
to use the use effect first use
effect you have already seen the use
effect earlier because it is holding the
life cycle related
conditions so now here we are saying
prep value okay dot
current
equal to
input val
okay and after that which value you are
seeing
we get updated so we are passing
value for sure
okay
post that once it is ready okay i'll be
saying return
okay inside this return
i'm having
div tag
and here in this div type we can say
input type
equal to
text
okay value
equal to which value would like to take
it so we are giving
input val
okay and we are also saying on change
equal to
taking this e is an event object here
and
we're calling
set
input val
with
e dot
target dot
value
okay
so we are holding the values
just like this
okay and after this once it is ready i
just want to use the
s3 tag
to show what is the current value so we
can say
updated value
okay here
i'm having this input value with me
and now i'll be using one more
h2 psa
last value of
using
priv
value
okay dot
current
so that's where you are basically using
so
this will be offering you what
the kind of value you are actually
expecting into your program
okay so use ref hooks can be used to
keep track of the previous state values
this is what we're doing it now
okay so this is because we are able to
persist
use reference value between the render
so now let me try to say
export
default
and
i'm just giving the name of
app and this app i'm using it here in my
app.js
app
let me terminate it and
launch it again
[Music]
let's see
local 3000 again
so it is taking some more time but i'm
sure
we'll be able to see the outcome soon
interval system so now you can see these
values are coming up so now when i pass
the value call
one it is containing the one when i say
two you can see it is holding the
previous value when i said three it
containing the previous value when i say
for it holding the previous value that's
where exactly the beauty of this
user of which you are expecting it from
all of you
so everyone we have already seen like
our previous example like how we can use
the use ref in our previous project now
it's time to talk about
our another interesting feature in
hooke's continuation to this
and that we're talking about called
working with a use reducer
so what is the use reducer see use
reducer is again a hook
which is as same as like in use state
okay it allows for
custom state logic
unlike the normal state how we maintain
using new state it allows to help
having some custom logic also see if you
are finding yourself where if you have a
call multiple portions of the state
that actually depends on the complex
logic use reducer would be very very
beneficial for you because it contains a
centralized logic
okay and can help the users to develop
some more fantastic applications so
let's see how we can actually do this
and how we can utilize that so in hooks
demo
i'm going to create a new file here i'm
going to give the name call
not
app.js
and in this node.js i would like to have
some initialize state i won't like to
make it available to the user
so
let's try to use one
very simple logic called
const
node reducer
node
reducer equal to here
i would like to take the parameter like
in state
and
action it is just like in normal
functionality we are writing it down
and inside this we would like to use a
switch
here we use a switch and we will judge
what type of action client is trying to
invoke action this is what kind of
condition client so client is ready to
invoke i'm using action
dot
type
okay and here we use the first option
like in case
first
condition i'm taking it is called
populate nodes
okay
populate underscore
which all the existing nodes are
available populated
okay and here
after this
we would like to say return
[Applause]
dot
nodes
okay or else in a default case
or in a default case
we are saying return
the default state whichever is available
to me
so that's how the condition is now
going back
i would like to also check what are the
type of
states are available which i would like
to show it back to the client so we are
using this option like it
const
let's create a states first we are
saying const
nodes
comma
dispatch equal to use
reducer and inside this rule is user
first parameter we are passing is called
node reducer whichever we have taken is
an action here
and comma the initial state which i'm
making it is a blank
i do not have any states of making it as
a blank again i'm using this option i
can const
title
set title equal to
use
state with initial value blank
so that's how we are passing it now
okay now the next thing is like i would
like to
check
in my code
how to basically
display the list of nodes back to my
application
okay that's what the whole logic i want
to write
okay so let's check in case if i want to
return
the bulk of nodes how will i do this
so here
let's try to create
the
nodes app so
this i would to make it that was the
reducer for us now here we're going to
create const
node
tab equal to
and i'm closing it here
okay so we are having these two
properties with me
and
i can have a number of actions also but
let's talk about return
in this return
we want to display the list of nodes
which are available to me
in case if i'm having it i will display
it so
i'm having the div tag
inside this dev tag i can say
h2
notes
after this notes
notes
dot map in case if i am having a array
of nodes map is a predefined function
for me so here we are using what
note
okay so
so inside this you would like to provide
the
object where the details will be
available to me
okay so
i can use the div tag
where i can have the property with me so
i can use
the div
okay so i can use
key
equal to
you can just use
the default sheet which is available on
notes
key equal to what notes
and provide
the other details too like if you want
to iterate it so you can just provide
the data accordingly
okay so
that's what the whole idea is
and here
under this we would like to provide
not
okay
and
here if in case if i want to have some
data that can be displayed
okay so
now say
export
default
note app
and this is not up i'll be making it as
a child of app.js
okay
you can see i have got initial data
displaying here so in case if i have few
more records
suppose if i set data
okay so you can basically make
this data also available here so you can
see our god list of records are
available
okay so
that's make your development even more
easier
and that's the beauty of how the nodes
can be used for the further development
okay so i hope you're clear about
what in case if i want to use
uh you know this reducer
so how we can further utilize it to
initialize
the data with this
but later on if i want to some add some
actions
i can also add it
okay but this is what the initial state
which we are using it
in case if i want to display the data in
my code
hello everyone so in the previous
sections we have seen like uh
how we will be utilizing
our you know use reducer applications
now i'm going to tell you about another
react very popular tool that is known as
called use memo which is once again a
very very popular tool so what is the
user memo it is again another hook so
use memo hook returns a memorized value
what it was the previous value was
so you can
say think of
uh
memorization as a caching value so that
it does not need to be recalculated it
already contain the value within that
so use memo only runs when
of its dependency update
okay so use memo
okay
is one of the very very popular tool but
it can be
you know little expensive resource
insensitive function
okay so it is
used memo can be used to keep expensive
and resource oriented function
to avoid needlessly running
so we will see how this
use memo can work
so let's check this out and see see
what my intention is in my application
is like
use memo is basically perform
some
actually memorized your complex
uh calculations so that it doesn't need
to run unnecessary every time
okay so it does a kind of caching
behavior for you to make your life even
more simple so let's see how it works so
accordingly you will also get the
implementations
okay so
you need to understand the use memo hook
accept the second parameter
okay to declare it dependencies so the
expensive function would only run when
this dependency has been changed
otherwise not
okay so let's see how we will be using
those so now here
i'm creating a new file and give the
name call
[Music]
memo.js
okay so inside your memo app.js what you
do is just take a look let me try to
close rest of those
yeah so here you see
okay so we are saying
set count
equal to
user state initialize value with what
i would say 0
for a time being i'm trying to use now
okay
and
after that if i want to perform some
calculations i can do that but let me
try to perform
this job only okay count and set count
according to my
rule
okay now
what i'm planning to do now is in a
similar line
i want to offer one more feature here
called const
equal to use state
i am making it as a what type area type
okay and i'm saying
const
calculation equal to
expensive calculation
and here we are passing what
counters and parameter here
okay now let's perform some functions
i'm saying const
increment equal to
set count
see
plus one
okay and we are using
we're calling this set to dos here
okay hence use
all the previous states whichever are
available and
new data this will get added so three
functions we are basically calling
after that i am saying
return
in this return i'm having what
div tag
within this div tag i can use
another div tag here and here we're
using
my
after this h2 we would like to use
to do dot
map
slash what index
and here we saying return
paragraph
sorry key
equal to
add task
okay and
here here
sorry
equal to what index here
and here
to do
[Music]
okay
how do you make it
okay so this is how we have it now
after this we would like to create a one
button
inside this button i can say
add to do
and here
we will say one click and in on click
will be calling
at task
so this is what it is happening now
okay everybody
so here after this
div tag is getting closed
hr is getting closed
again we are opening up another div tag
here
and here we are seeing
count
and here we are using
in this button we would like to
click on plus
increment what we're calling it here
increment here and
call something called
calculation
just like a normal message and here
put what
calculation
okay so once it is done
so your dip tag is also close
both the two tags are getting closed
okay and they are also getting close and
now
we would like to perform one function
whichever i would like to use it for my
standard calculation
okay so let's see what we are trying to
do so here i am saying
programming calculation equal to
okay and we are using this
lock button inside this lock button i'm
saying
[Music]
calculating here and post this
this thing is called for
let
i equal to 0
is
less than
[Music]
okay and we're using what
i
plus plus
and say
now
equal to one
okay
and after this
i can say
return
now
and after that i'll be rendering this
function
by saying
export default memoir
that's it
okay
so this would be my application here
okay so now
here in this example
the expensive function which is called
long running function
okay
whatever i'm talking about
the long running function okay will only
run when the count is changed
and not when the to-do's are added
that's a whole picture about this code
here
okay so you can just see here
we are using this statement
and
here
we're gonna give the name of this
long running calculations
to here
okay so i'm calling it there
now this memo app i'll be using it in my
app.js
okay so that is what we have it now so
i'm clearly saying like here so
in this application
hook accept second parameter to declare
dependency this exp so the long running
functions will only run when the
dependency have changed otherwise not
that's the whole picture
so it is adding it saying calculating it
and then it is getting changed
okay
so that's what the whole picture of what
we have done so i'm sure like you all
are clear
about how
this memo is really performing some job
the one which is actually expected
and once again we're going to start with
another feature of books as we have got
many hooks seen in our development
okay and
now on this top of this i'll be working
on our new concept that is what's called
use imperative handler
it is again a new concept as we have
already seen multiple different type of
hooks into our development now we'll be
talking about use imperative handler
now what is the use of
this particular hook look when we talk
about use imperative handler if i just
get you this
so if i say
use
now when we talk about use imperative
handler
okay so this use reparative handler and
the user is what we've already done
allows to pass a reference object
but the later which is called
use reference
which you've already seen
this use reference
doesn't allow to customize the instance
that are
also passed with the ref object so use
imperative handler hooks is a different
from user friends
because it allows again it allows
handling and customizing the return
value
it allows handling and customizing the
return value
and it also allows to replace the native
instance of the ref object
now how it works let's try to understand
in our development
so
here we're going to start working with a
very simple approach
into our code
okay
so we're going to create a new one that
is called
[Music]
imperativedemo.js and after this we are
writing
function
inverted
okay here we are passing two parameters
here one is called
props
and seconds call what two parameters we
are passing it
now here we are saying
const
user if
okay
now
after this we're using use
you can see we have called use
imperative handler comes from
this one so we are using this use
imperative handler and here we are
passing what refers in parameter
okay and
okay now in this case we are using one
type of functionality called blur
okay and here with this blur
and we are using
log
and writing
custom blur is called
after this once it is ready i would like
to say return
in this return
we are saying button
okay
and with this button
i want to use ref
okay equal to
btn and
props
we both are passing in here
in this using
click
okay
that's it and
once it is done then
we would like to use this
okay into my application
wherever i can actually access this
in my application system
so once it is ready i would like to make
it
available so by using i'm saying export
default and i'm using something called
forward reference
you can see it is again a part of what
the react application we are using is
called forward reference
and here you're passing what
button so that is what my code is
now here
i will be making it as a child off but
[Music]
in my app.js so we already have this
earlier
memoir so here in my application
i'm just using const
btn equal to
use reference
i'll be using what use reference
so react and i'm using
okay so we're using this option called
use reference here and we are passing
null here and after this
this value which over here having it we
just said cut
and passing it here
and this under this written keyword i'm
using
button
and in this button in our
options i can provide the events
so inside this button we would like to
one second yep
so inside this button using
one click
equal to
we are saying btn okay dot
current dot
okay so we haven't imported
anything so let me import a button from
here
okay so we say
import
button
which class you have created here
imperative demo
okay
so
so once it is there so
[Music]
so we're providing what btn dot current
dot
blur
so closing this here and along with this
we are saying ref
equal to
btn
that's it
so this is where exactly the options are
so you understand in this particular
example we have developed a custom
button component that has a user defined
instance attached to the reference
object
attached to the what the reference
object now so we have developed the
button component that has a user defined
instance attached to the reference
object so button component is a child
component of the app component
are we clear so when we click the button
here
the button is clicked
okay it called user defined blur
function which is attached to the pass
reference object
okay so that's the whole idea now
so i haven't tried anything another
button
that certainly i can add it
so under here
okay
so now
okay so
here
the things are working the way we were
expecting
okay so you see like what we did here is
now
we are now using this approach
okay you see like we are using this
approach with using this
use empirical reference so we have a
call function button
we're passing two parameter props in ref
so we're getting this use reference
object
and use imperative we are passing this
ref
and this object here so we are using
this blur
as an
kind of custom objects where console.log
custom
properties getting called a reference
button equal to
button and you're saying dot or dot
props click here button and export
default forward reference button here
and followed by app.js
we are just using this
normal app component
const button equal to use reference null
return we are returning this button
on click
you see here equal to btn
okay it's just a reference what you're
using dot
current dot blur
and uh after that is getting close using
f equal to what btn whichever you're
referring it and that's it so the job is
done
[Music]
so friends now after this the previous
example we have seen called imperative
now it's time to basically discuss about
another very interesting example that is
called use layout effect there is
another hook which is available to you
so this use layout effect actually works
similar
okay
to use use effect but rather working
asynchronously like what a use effect
does because use effect works
asynchronously
it fires synchronously after all
loading is done
again i'm repeating
the use layout effect works similar to
use effect but rather than
but rather working asynchronously like
how the use effect works okay what it
does is it basically it fires
synchronously after all norm
is done loading so this is pretty useful
for normally a synchronously
re-rendering the dom
okay so it is very useful for
synchronously re-rendering the dom and
also to read the layout
from the dock
but to prevent
blocking the page loading we should
always use use effect otherwise it will
block
so the use layout effect
okay works in the same phase as
in mount and component did update
methods we should only use use effect
layout effect if use effect is not
outputting the expected result
so let's take a look with a simple
example the one which we are looking
forward for
okay so here in my code what we're doing
is
we're gonna give the new file name
called use
dot
okay so let me add
constant
layout
okay
and here we're using const
equal to
use state
and give any value whichever you would
like to give it okay let's say
welcome
and after that
you come down and say
use layout effect
okay and say if
value
equal to
welcome
i am saying
set value
welcome to react hooks
okay so that's an expectations and after
that we are using what
the log and inside this length is saying
used layout is working
okay with value so
using what the value
here okay
and
whenever the value changes
and listening to what the value here
and after this when we talk about return
so you have to return the value ht
okay so we say
return
inside this tip we will say
value
that's it
and after this
left
in here
okay
so once it is ready you will see here
in your program
okay we need to check
[Music]
so
a value okay all right so here i need to
use
to make it okay so now
i go to the inspect
go to the console
let's refresh
and now you can see it is loading
synchronously
okay
so your application is now loading the
way it
[Music]
so that's where the idea of this
particular example so
in this example we have built a name
changer application that changes the
name of the state when the used layout
effect is called
okay and it's working fine
okay everyone so now if it is ready then
we'll be talking about our next feature
here
that is called working with
use debug value
this is once again another hook
of the react based development
so when we talk about use double value
so what used value actually does and
what we uh really do
with the use debug value this we would
like to understand
okay see what happens not too many
developers nowadays know about
use debug value hook okay though
although it provides a much better
debugging experience when it comes to
the developing custom books so use debug
value is a simple in-built hook that
provides more information about the
logical
of a custom mode within a reactive tool
so react devtool is a tool which you can
get it downloaded for your chrome
extension
okay
and
it allows you to display the additional
information
okay
next to your hooks with optional
formatting
okay so that's what the
redux
react
views debug value is basically be useful
for
now how you basically use this so you
can just consider in this way
if i just go back and create a new file
and give the name called usable value
use
differ
okay
so inside this youtuber.js
here we would like to use function
and function we can use this option i
can use
friend status
use frame status so here
we can say
trend
and here we can use const
is
online
set
online equal to
and here i told you is
online
question mark
here we say
online
okay and here
we say what
okay and after this we are talking about
this option what written
okay
so that's where exactly you perform
this condition for after that what you
can do you can just use this option i
can export
default
trendline online status
so this is where you can
basically perform this online debugging
sorry the debugging for all the
react hooks whichever you looking
forward for so this is very popular and
utilized and useful option for the
regular users
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here